once god recognizes so god also
disappears like when you truly recognize
itself the self disappears right it's
like the wind when it comes to wind the
sky becomes the sky it doesn't feel
itself doesn't label itself
the only reason why you're not like as
fast as the sky is because of the things
that you haven't looked at that's it
right doing nothing is like lifting
weights bro
especially in the beginning where you
haven't done nothing ever before you
know
all cameras that comes down to that
really just sensation trying to untangle
all the sensations the the way i always
describe it is the middle way is more
like
what transcends both sides of the
duality which includes both sides of the
quality
but you need to kind of max out on both
sides to be able to transcend them so
yeah whatever you're feeling as a ground
is the curricula for dissolution
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly
i mean what more can we like the end of
measurements to say yeah
exactly
here we are frank yang welcome back
hello alice
it's good to see your teeth
you too
same
have you been
so good
so good my brother
you did
yes
yeah
yeah
i'm actually really happy we took that
long break so that we could deepen and
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah i totally agree
yeah
somebody asked me if uh awakening is
like an on and off suit or it goes on
forever i said both right yeah yeah i
said there is an on off switch at least
for me
and then
make sure whatever you want to call it
deep in the realization
and it goes on forever
right yeah i'm not the one who said that
i mean i
i agree with that but i hear a lot
because like life
is integration right and life the that's
what i like to call the influence
feature now because
it's constantly morphing you know
it's constantly shape-shifting
right yeah that's life
yes
even though the state like you want
whatever i want to call it nonduali
naturals they want to call it after the
shift it's the same but the
highest manifested and integrated
to your you know
changes every now and then
like you said it's like uh you said it
earlier it's like a workout like a once
an 80 workout right
yeah
right and recently you were talking
about becoming the best athlete
yes yes i always used handling
the differences though
have after realization after the
dealership is violated it just happens
like whatever integration is going to
happen it just happens
and
your desire is absolutely no different
from life's desire
yeah and then i realized that the
realization is
whatever you do even though it's more
controlled
it's just about life it's the best place
to live
it's like you can't go you can't go
wrong yeah
yeah yeah like there are certain things
i have to like
well you sound like oh i got like a
little decorative for that oh i gotta
meditate too
like all that's been dissolved right
right but the places that this thing is
taking me like sort of what you want to
call universal well with us
you realize that
it's taking a place that you never
expect before
and there's not a
there's not
yeah
yeah yeah even
it's like you sit in the backseat pretty
much
right
that's definitely knowledge
and then
before you're sitting in the front seat
driving is the ego and then throughout
the integration you kind of
at first you're in the back seat you're
like okay [ __ ]
crazy this is just like god just gave me
this like infinite car to drive how do i
drive this i don't know we even know
where the key
where the buttons right then you try to
figure out how to drive it
but then after a while you just realized
the car's driving itself you didn't do
anything
and then the places that this car was
like in the backseat with your feet up
yeah like i said earlier just unexpected
places
it's not even it's not even a point of
expectation it's not even like oh my god
i didn't expect it just
oh okay this is what it is
yeah since our last conversation
so many more of the things that you had
been sharing
became
deeper and deeper
in direct experience and realized
and
the most
shattering dissolving one was shifting
from the concept of god
into emptiness
oh okay yeah yeah and then that that was
a whole
different
uh realization yeah
[Laughter]
just so we don't confuse our viewers
uh i still use the word god but i use
that interchangeably
to like reality
business or just the mind or
whatever like well some people like god
and i guess that we're just confused
right but and this is what you think
about the shift
and the key thing was being a person
with the concept
versus being the
nothingness the energy itself which
isn't a thing and it's everything and so
that that shift happening in the spring
was
crazy
yeah
and then that's where the no the no
doership and the no center started
emerging more and more organically and i
noticed that that emptiness and love
being those two sides of the same coin
started emerging more and more too more
and more yeah so this the spaciousness
and the surrender to whatever was
arising was so
taking over and it was so beautiful and
perfect no resistance to
even if it would be some like
roaring of someone's conditioning in a
yelling screaming way there would just
be equanimity
even even if it would pinball off into
some uh
desire to respond for a second that
their equanimity would just
i'm so open to healing this
yeah yeah
yeah man one of the inside
that i got was
bondage is freedom even
even when you feel contracted away
yeah even when you contracted sometimes
it's not really contraction it's just
the the doing the state due to the
constant effect of
different origination whatever
so it's like
before there was a resistance to that
resistance
or another is that before you were still
trying to let go like you're trying to
surrender
then you realize that there's no point
to try to surrender after you sort of
let go of blood pill you stop giving a
[ __ ] about like
i'm i'm i'm trying to create this
spacious
i'm trying to be this awareness
when she rises like now i gotta do my
own
you might like you know right right for
expansion thing but
i mean it just happens
or like try to like get back into a
certain state yes
right yeah yeah
every state now is
yeah yeah even the stages are awakening
when we talk about
see if when i was making that i was
i was i know i know this
is ultimately false but i will
slightly attach the uh the no
self-emptiness
things because i was going through that
out like that
i had just stepped out of the cockpit
and now even that's gone
the self and no self
integrated together
that's really like your desire the
universe you want to even call it
desired one
like the human aspect very important
yeah
yeah and that
has uh
beautifully come up as bringing the
celestial terrestrial or the the air
into earth
and making it cellular uh
yeah like making every moment not just
like sometimes
or like as a concept yeah it's the
infinite definer
right and i and i'm feeling more and
more
that
sort of that that end of
it all
seeking
um
also expressed similarly like you were
just referencing which is very much like
the middle way like even bondage is
freedom itself
and so there's there's no urge to
change anything
so yeah meaning it's all perfect as it
is and so um there's no desire to change
infinity
to
wake up
because yeah yeah yeah
i even lost that desire to talk about
this stuff
it's like the like i said really every
state is equally valid you know the eco
state like awareness states whatever
god
state
ramen love
most of emptiness it's all
the same
but one but once you're going through it
it's like holy [ __ ] i thought that was
it this is something else yeah yeah but
all of that it's just a reaction of the
rest of it even the labels of the
different stages you know or or the
experiences of it
either like spiritual highs or
spirituals or however you want to
quantify it
it's just the the remainder of the
seeker or the remainder of the
conditioning is still trying to figure
out what the [ __ ] is going on
but he's still dissolving the process of
dissolving the process of physically
dissolving your body mind you're going
to experience
that process the same process
but the mind the mind
responds to those different openings
and it's a little different different
taste in each stage
and the more you dissolve the bigger the
opening the more you experience
divinity you know light whatever yes you
know it didn't have to look like even
that's
integrated and
like i said like once god recognizes god
also disappeared when you
really recognize this thought myself
disappears right it's like
right
right
and
it's been really important for the
seeker to exhaust itself in the process
to sort of keep
going as the sense of self doesn't feel
like it's gone and then question well
what is the cause of the proliferation
of that identity and location and sense
of others and that kind of thing and
then
um
that's really been a helpful way of of
looking at it is this sort of
proliferation from spaciousness or from
emptiness like just seeing those
proliferations seeing where there's
resistances well why is there no why is
there a resistance there and then like
kind of turning
the eye on itself and just being like
where is it in the body
what right what have i what have i
locked in cellularly into a contraction
somewhere and
is it something about my life something
about some story some traumas some
shadows and how can i
ease my way into it and sort of unlock
that and
let that go express it and let it go
yeah yeah
just the stuff uh you
look at really
the stuff that you have
the only reason why you're not like
this is the sky is because things you
haven't looked at right
[Laughter]
and most people like spend their whole
life running away from from that yeah
you know like that's why you tell normal
people to just sit down for like
10 minutes not even a retreat
just don't do anything for 20 minutes
then what i want to do you know look at
that
yeah
because the nature of
it reveals itself through do nothing
and yeah yeah and it's really scary
that's why
it's very scary
especially where's the end when there's
like a tiny bit of resistance left but
even though the sensations are
the effect
like the trigger point is
because that's the only thing that your
whole life is dependent on
yeah
like if you like you're gonna die and if
you don't let go you're gonna there's
nothing you can do
it usually starts with the head
ultimately in the waking of the mind the
heart the solution of the chest hair
and then all the deepest conditions are
stored in the gut the clothes will dig
right
yeah and then when you have that opener
that's when you lose the viewer
yeah like when you open up the mind you
know you lose the seer thinker here
whatever then when you go all the way
down
the bottom of your nervous
that's when the
worship knocks and they it's the same
process
it's deeper and deeper yeah so it is
from
the do it with the cosmos
right
right the gut and those lower energy
centers are such a deep store of those
[Music]
that really
badly want to be expressed to be
released uh into greater freedom into
sky
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah and a big part of the end of
seeking is also the end of questions
also
oh yes
in your head like it's just a voice in
your head that's coming down this
process that's already happening
it's not like you can do anything about
it i mean during the process you just
feel like you have to try harder for
most people but after a while
there's nothing you could do about it
the voice in your head is commenting on
this oh where your path
or question things about reality you
know
consciousness what is god
uh what is this made up of and then
at the end the voice is complete
i'm so quiet there's no more questions
coming in
and every one of those questions is so
important for the seekers journey
yeah and and there's a way to
be more efficient by asking those bigger
questions off the bat as quickly as you
can like what what is reality what is
god what is this field what what is all
of this um yeah as what is a sensation
what is energy if you really get to that
stuff faster
instead of like playing in the noise
let's say um find the needles in the
haystack
right right and then it'll
create a greater
um
dissolution of the center faster um
yeah i agree yeah that's why a lot of
people that go on the path started
asking these questions are young
yeah
and the
i think it's important the question
but uh at the end the answer is right
everything is that i mean that's what
the zheng kong every single zen khan has
it's just this all right yeah
but then you're
it's so difficult to talk about this
because when you tell people this is it
or like
is this
unless you went through the whole
unfoldment
it's very difficult to understand where
you're talking they're going to relate
their current
levels of my consciousness to the water
so a lot of people just say oh there's
nothing to do
but the what is important after the
practice
uh finish at least to that point uh is
completely different
it's like i always tell people
you put the frankie
in this experience right now which is
quite ordinary like even just like a
month before
another shift
you'll lose his mind
yeah
yeah but it's all rough
yeah yeah and and another good way to
put it that
will i feel like we'll continue
elaborating on in the content that we
create is that
there
there seems to be some sort of a
like a
like a heads up display that has a bunch
of like concepts and ideas and
identities and whatnot and
the
inquiry process
is sort of like dissolving those like
assumptions and identities and location
and all that kind of stuff
and then you sort of
that loop closes on on itself and you
sort of see you see what it's like to
not have a heads-up display
like where there's no
identity no location
no
ideas no concepts total innocence
um
just
beautiful surrender um
you know that kind of thing and
it's a really good analogy in some ways
to to video games people are aware of
playing the games with the heads up
display and what it's like to not have a
a display of tons and tons of little
icons basically and stuff that you're
constantly managing with your mind and
like pinballing yourself between them
endlessly
um
so it's like the cessation of that
thousands of times
yeah so it's like when the video game
just plays itself there's no need to
have icons telling you
what to do pretty much
even the icon of emptiness and love and
even i am
even empty destiny
no self even even awakening
right
but it's really hard to follow when you
press this card but just like you pulled
down afterwards and you attain those
different realizations
you access those different consciousness
and let all that go
in a sense it's almost like
i think ramana mahashi says something
similar when he's like one of his like
final teachers like almost not ready for
that
it's the part of the spiritual
the the part of the secret
part of the seeker just has to end yeah
and then
you go on the spiritual path and you
dissolve it supposedly dissolves all of
the program
the city on the of spirituality the last
program
there's a police officer
yeah and the
solution of that is
it's like we talked about earlier i mean
this wasn't the core like the gut
and it's not like spirituality itself is
the problem it's just that the rest of
the company
what does it have to happen everything
else i can see
yeah
right and there's a such a like a
beautiful
subtle solidity of spirituality and
awakening that's there and it just
yeah wants to proliferate itself um
around as emptiness is equal to form and
that this is all infinity or endlessness
and it's all one field and um you
investigate your sense of self to wake
up and
and then just letting go of even that
and just
just like
so what's left it's just groundless
and yeah it's scriptless
um
and it's just beauty and um
and yeah even there's just such high
it's just beautiful also equanimity
through even the sensation that is uh
some sort of pain or um
yeah it's
yeah this is a whole different ballpark
um
yeah yeah
this is it's uh
so all the stuff you went through in
spirituality is like transcendence of
the stuff like a temporary precipitation
and the dropping away of yourself
permanent dropping
in a different ballpark and any mystical
any metallic stage
and what i described what's left after
you
oh
just a dental state
um
and you can't comprehend this at all
with the the rest of the solidity with
the rest of the song
like you just can't like and then that's
why i i don't even know how to talk
about this you know because i
they still kind of need
some kind of anchor on yeah because if
you give this thing to a person too
early they're gonna
you're
oh you you didn't realize anything this
is kind of true i think
you have to kind of package it in a more
or less like a
way that people can kind of use an
anchor to impact
you know
for them to like feel or else
yeah they're either gonna think like
you're crazy or they're gonna think um
they haven't done anything i i don't
need to do
you know or that you know there's
nothing to do sure yeah yeah
and ultimately
but
for the seekers
and it does feel like the in many ways
the
threefold training
is
such a direct
way for the seeker to
investigate itself um
because
morality is very common across all
religions and philosophies
um and so it's unique to whatever that
entity
feels like is moral whatever is good and
etc and
um
and of course there's if it feels like
commonalities uh like the more that you
feel the interconnection of everything
um
like
this can't believe what i think the more
ethical you are exactly like this can't
live without
the phytoplankton and trees everything's
in that interdependent
cycle and so when he's and so that means
all life is in that interdependence
cycle with itself and so this like
living breathing pulsing morphing cycle
and so then
if you really sort of anchor in that
first thing of morality which is like
the
when sort of self-awareness kind of
boils up you could say that morality is
one of the first places that it tends to
go
and then
and then
along with that if concentration or
focus
is
is
desired um and it's applicable to all
parts of life it's not just um
meditation and inquiry but it's also
you know well why am i a slave to social
media
why can't i focus for more than um five
seconds on someone who's talking to me
why am i already lost and waiting for my
my own turn to speak or whatever it is
and so concentration focus uh helps you
develop in all aspects of life like even
a greater sense of empathy with like
listening to someone talk all of these
types of ways so concentration helps and
then
through morality and concentration
wisdom is gradually revealed more and
more and that's that's i feel like it's
just such a classical
um perennial pointing that style that
approach
yeah for the viewers that don't know
what we're talking about he's talking
about the um
what is it called the threefold training
boo buddha's three full training
morality
um concentration
yeah
yeah
yeah there we go yeah
in the whole integration thing because
i think the whole integration process
moralities
yeah i i didn't last long about reality
is until like after
i maxed out the list
yeah for some people they i mean you can
pretty much
connect all three
pillars if you just
take one to the stream
um
the morality
uh
the workers certainly pretty much
infinite like you can just keep going
with that
be more acidic
just be a better person
but the inside
with some accessories
you know when revealed
you close the loop or whatever losing
this
but even after that the rest of the the
conditioning still has to be
tucked into the the emptiness and that
process is of
constitution
you're talking about the surfacing right
of those conditions yeah just yeah the
surface
after you
after you access you put the switch on
the wall all your conditionings are not
like evaporated to the line to true by
the way this is impossible like most
teachers it takes up to like seven
years or like ten years and completely
um
you know i don't know how i'm just
taking a moment right now but like on
the conventional level that does make
sense
and even though there's nothing more you
can do on the wisdom access development
after you um
you know reach the end of that
the morality part
concentration you can always
you're being proved
and the three they go you go um
they really feel like
the way that you
you can't really see unless you really
bring up the morale
because it's like
if you
how concentrated are you going to
be
just kind of meditating or even just you
know to
your mind you know filled up with what
you like
your girlfriend or like just to have the
things right some stuff
right you know
you don't have concentration you can't
punish your reality you can like you
know develop solidity and reveal the
word
and the more wisdom the more you can see
holy [ __ ]
i'm such an [ __ ]
or i was
it's to a certain degree
you know i could always be a better
person
yeah yeah and then
yes yeah i'm noticing that um in
integration is the
terrestrialization or the earthing or
the embodiment of the celestial and
whatnot the air um yeah realizations and
the insights and
the integration
i've noticed
has
a deepening when one distances
themselves a little bit at least from
the games of identity and the games of
civilization um the games of self and
others and lack and all that stuff so
meaning the more time that you take and
this is why again alone
alone alone because
just like in the theravada buddhism uh
the
the retreats the ten day silent retreats
um right those you you're s you're you
do you know how to shut up for ten
straight days and not say a word do you
know how to not use technology for 10
straight days
do you know how to not talk to people
all that kind of stuff
and
what you see is that in your integration
if you also stop all your social media
postings and communications stop texting
and calling um and only just tune in to
like the go go and wake up and sunbathe
like lay out in the sun listen to nature
to mother nature um go to the gym take
care of your body the fitness side the
nutrition side of things and just
lay and do nothing
be nothing be no one don't engage in
goal achievement and attainment and just
do nothing be no one and just keep do
over i mean that's that's integral
doing nothing it's like lifting weights
bro
especially in the beginning you haven't
done nothing ever before you know
yeah
damn it yeah you and you'll see how
quickly that little urge to want to
communicate your insight on social media
you'll you'll you'll yeah yeah you'll
see that
you'll finally you know
i know i've been through that myself so
i can see in other people like i'm not
judging them
i did the same thing
like after shift like after like
matter
i see a lot of people like they just go
on social media
just posting about it i mean i think
that's great too there's plus and like
minus size to this i think it's great
that you share it because first of all
you share you're also kind of dissolving
as well so it's a way to dissolve
right
and you saw other people get something
out of it that's great
but there can't be like a fine like
there could be a balance that you kind
of
you do it too much they can
overshoot yourself you know
but if you don't share at all that's
also like
middleweight
middleway right it's in the middle
exactly yeah yeah yeah
yeah right so it's it's neither
neither it's not yeah neither sharing
nor silence you know something like that
yeah
exactly like the one the first the first
discord that the blue
game was called the middleweight right
so you went to those aztecs
accents how do you say that that's
aesthetic aesthetics yes ascetics
addicts all right
right so he met a bunch of aesthetics i
just mentioned
um they don't even go out they just
don't even
they're just like
torturing themselves
and then but i went through that like
this is not the way because you're just
not completely more resistant to
creating this stuff
no there's nothing
you know
uh and then
i mean he was a point
first so he went did the whole like
debauchery like
already and then he went the other way
of the extreme
instead
and then he walked out of there and that
he has to breathe
and told them that's not the way i mean
for i guess for some people it is
but
at least for the people that i've seen
right with
right middleweight
is bad right
just like to meditate you've always
asked me can i do like contraction
practices like do posture on my legs or
should i do meditation or just relax
i'm like they're too snappy
that's the same
and that speaks a lot that the first
teaching was middleway that that should
be a big indicator of
of this
so what what does that sort of mean to
be in the middle between
emptiness and form or whatever two poles
that you want to
like what does it mean to be in the
middle or in a superposition of them
both at the same time and neither of
them
and
then you get into the indescribable and
the ineffable
right
the the way i always describe it is the
middle way is more like
what transcends both sides of the
duality which includes both sides of the
body
but you need to kind of max out on both
sides to be able to incentive
the inconceivable it's really uh just
the notion that
um
emptiness is also just conceivable right
because it's empty of possibility yeah
and if you look at physics they delve
really
natural reality over atom
going down to the particles in the
subatomic level
like you know springs
quantum level realize that the people
that get into react
the market you can see
right
like richard fives including quantum
mechanics
quantum mechanics i think it could be
step by step did you think you
understand god
do you um you understand the song or
whatever you're doing
whatever he's trying to because he is
inconceivable but then this thing really
it's not like the mind doesn't know
it's like
it's not like an ignorant of the mind
it's like you become reality so much
that you can't see itself yeah
that's the the way i describe it yeah
so it's not like you're going away from
you actually
experience experiencing yourself at a
much deeper level your realization
becomes much deeper when you let go of
your identity your identification
realization
um and or your desire to know whether
or any kind of answers or questions are
generated by the mind
you know what is reality um what it
can't just grab all that and spin mode
or a constant reality that there's a
point that's not even your vocabulary
but it's that the experience was
like a better word business can
itself
more complete because if there's still a
reality between like what's knowing
what's
knowing it no you know
if you if you think you might you'll
know something
yeah they're still
knowing the note
and until that
point when it feels like it
has fully closed the loop on itself and
then
there's
whatever it is for it to
ignite itself
um
which is really just igniting its own
um
dissolutions of its own assumptions
about
um
self and others and world and identity
and location all that kind of stuff um
as those things fall apart then it knows
itself more and more cleanly and then it
ends its own seeking and it ends its own
questioning and it means it ends its own
uncomfortability
ends its own
resistance um
and it can sort of allow
the rawness of sensation to be as it is
and be in full love with that and yeah
yeah yeah because it knows itself as the
as itself as this whole
uh you oh oh yeah cosmic octopus to
bring that back from our uh
yeah it's just all of those
sensings that are happening and um
and there's nothing but love for itself
so it just it just it just spaciously
opens its heart up to whatever
conditioning needs to unravel itself and
then it just holds that loving space and
um
whether it's a parent or a friend or
someone that needs to heal or whatever
um
yep
so what else are you
i'm just i just miss you so much man i'm
i'm so excited to play
yeah i love playing
i still love talking about this wow but
it's just from different places
yeah i miss the same thing
you know it's like
it's not a necessity necessity for me
anymore to like want to share no i still
do i like
it's not like a mission
like right
to prove some
hard to
wake up
well that's gone
right
right
gosh
and that's that's the thing is
kind of
like
feeling um the whole
um and just sort of allowing it to
suffer
oh okay like i mean in this sense of
like allowing
um
the
polarized propaganda
and the
the hatred and the egos and the
separation and the not knowing itself as
the whole like allowing that suffering
to happen like seeing that that is
infinity knowing itself in that way and
that it exactly yeah so
the sort of the urge to
to
when when somebody speaks from a partial
perspective when they're not like
speaking from the whole there's no
longer the urge to want to insert itself
to change that perspective to be more
holistic all right only only when that
entity turns on itself and wants to know
how to feel more holistic
then it's pure for
um asking a question and then seeing
that
itself is just reflecting to itself how
to see more holistically to let go of
the center to let go of the self um
and that's healing for it so it no
longer
feels so
charged basically just charged in some
sort of
um it it's just some sort of like hatred
that it's like the social conditionings
that brew in a collective where there's
got to be someone to point and say is
the other and then hate and then make
propaganda about why to hate them and it
just happens between you know the two
sides of the political
polls in a country or um it happens
between nations in that way um it's just
that and then to really feel okay with
that totally equanimous about that
it's it's one's own healing from the
social conditioning itself
right
and those that
can feel it can also feel it in these
silences
you can feel it when you just
hug your
mom dad
or friend
in a long embrace and you just don't
feel like you're there
where are you
that's what we're talking about
and so even if you feel a lot of
solidity
you can really
feel it in these
begin to feel it in these just simple
exchanges
oh yeah tell me about that you said
like how did you make that
like was that um
you said um the
problem
right the identification how to
right
beyond that i'm sure right
you hear about this like a lot of people
oh i yeah you know i feel like
i guess
it's uh
right yeah
so it's one one of the
fun ways to put it is like adi shanti
says coming to the end of your rope
so
so
and even just in the spring
um
spring what is right now
fall
yeah what's the summer we're entering
end of summer entering into fall so
several months has been it's been like
this
and
you know i'll say even these simple
things like you know rob berbea and
seeing that freeze which you initially
hinted me towards
right even just these simple things like
when i'm introduced to the idea of
proliferation
even just that
you know that
it just
consists
right so it's like the proliferation of
the sense of self and others and
identity and location separation
well
well because i i hadn't made the click
before that um nibana
being gone was actually about the
cessation of weaving so like you're done
weaving you've stopped weaving so
meaning you've stopped proliferating
right
right okay right right and so that's why
and so at that time in the spring i was
like
wow just by
sort of finding these needles in the
haystack um right it can sort of create
a greater
like
more sudden shift and then that
gradually empties
um those conditions that surface
and uh
and so yeah it's just
i i've also
really sort of been enjoying um
identitylessness
i think that's another good way to
to
share what the
this the spaciousness um
the love feels like
um
and so it really feels like being more
and more gone and it's uh it's quite
nice and it's
it's very it's very cellular it used to
be very conceptual i've
and many times have been reflected that
i have a very sharp mind and that comes
from the studying of so many of these
concepts and ideas and
it's so tempting especially in
that's the to exactly i know yeah to be
yeah i know that concept ninja
yeah it's like um you have to let go of
your intellect and that's a really
heartbreak especially in your whole life
you've been conditioned to think that
you're the smart person you actually
like i know after that about 10 years
like 15 years you know i was really i
think
my mind my brain you know
how creative i was how smart i was books
i read
how much like smart content i was
pointing out
yeah and then
and it's the ironies that
a lot of people have gone on the path
got on fat because obviously are very
good thinkers that they questioned
and they inquired some things in the
atmosphere tomorrow
and feeling the same hair is very simple
and super smart you know but then like
that's the the weapon that they've been
using but at the end you have to let
that weapon go too
yeah
and that that's one of the hardest
things i had to do
it's like before i was like oh this
prank came
frankie was a bob
and then
but then they got my
deeper after you let go i would say my
intellect became sharper after
yes whatever you like you actually
you become it that's why i say
so that's the subtle difference between
the god conscious face god realization i
know self is like at the cafe sure you
access
the
infinite awareness and
that's that's basically just dissolving
the rest of your condition
once you get to the very end it's almost
like there's still a particle
in the center and if there's a particle
a point there's going to be a
circumference
but without that point
the conference is also
so i'll say like the whole
bio-consciousness of this thing or like
jonas and all this because
it's still a thing for a lot of people
because there's still a point here you
kind of measure it you know try to
attach it yeah
to try to experience it to try and look
at it
from
once that point is gone so it is the
compliment that's true infinity but then
at this point you don't even
have infinity anymore
they end up equally bra
right
and and and so those with all those
notions about like distance and death
yeah
even just like you know
i'll just hear the positive
figure
all that's
eventually getting up it's like the
archival man right you know it's you
know you're in a commercial world
there's depth and distance and colors
and characters there you can see
but then you know they're not real
that's what would it that means by um
emptiness really known here in existence
right so when you take out the goggles
the exact same thing
yeah it's just the fabrication
they look in your hand right now i'm
looking at the hand of your goggle just
anything that's going on
yeah
and uh there's no depth here there's no
so it's like you're permanently stuck in
a beyonce
that's that again going back to you
like worse like
ability and suchness yeah you know about
this like you've never actually seen
yourself you actually don't know what
you're looking at
yeah like even just like whole notion of
the self you know it's like the only
reason why i thought i had a self is
because i thought i knew what i was
looking at or what i was feeling if i
close my eyes and this image of frank
can't pop into my head i know that's me
my feeling associated with drinking i
know that's me but you don't know what
those decisions are
completely
right yeah you don't know what it is
apart from the representation of it
right well what is the representation of
nothing
some formless mystery
yeah it's just a complete mystery it's a
completely
yeah
yeah and then it's like
you kind of also go beyond this whole
duality of like idealism versus
realism
or like celebicism you find the middle
way actually because you realize it's
always mine sure
but that doesn't tell you anything about
what the mind is
that doesn't tell you that you're the
only mindex that exists so it's not
exactly solipsism and it's not exactly
materialism either because you never
actually experienced form of
you know the the tutorials and the
perceptual uh apprentice and experience
which is not exactly physical
rock it's inspiration somewhere
nothing i don't know where right
and but you know you can't deny that the
existence of an external world either no
one exists you know that's just jumping
into another side of the extreme
so i actually think that's a really
great middle way to to be in
yeah everything is
but then doesn't mean that you're the
only magnetic there's a lot of people
that
ellipses and
they just kind of put
their sense of
like this you know grand
just don't know what the [ __ ] is
yeah and that's that view that's what it
means
yeah
right
i found what
what we
um mentioned in this last bit about
vr to be
so helpful
um so go and put on
a vr headset and have the
experience
it's a good way to practice and and then
also
as we mentioned earlier
there's like all these when you're doing
this vr you can see it as all these
different like icons right of
oh
i am this body mind a name
and i
see all these other body mind and names
and my relation to them
my own beliefs and ideas concepts
and
my own resistances and all these things
these are like the little icons on the
vr
and so
a good way to sort of
tune into this as we've been referencing
is what happens when all of those things
are dissolved
all of those
all those solidities are decontracted
they're unwinded unknotted untangled
and then the headset knows itself
and also does not know how
crazy
mysterious
whatever this is is
yeah
and it's a big thing to ask
a heads
a headset and a headset entity to
to
ask itself
are you actually your
identity and location
right
so that's if you really want to get to
the
needle fast ask yourself that and
inquire into that and
and retain a high level of focus during
do nothing and vipassana style inquiry
and very quickly
um you'll unwind it more and more and
you'll become more kind of bouncy and
playful and loving in
the whole field and it's just
it's sort of it's what you seek but
you're kind of looking for it in the vr
headset itself instead of in um sort of
unwinding all of the contractions of the
headset
yeah yeah we're just asking the person
how insanely
his friend or him
but on the vr
things that the character is actually
here for like
the depth and distance and locations in
the video game are actually there
yeah so you actually waking up from the
identification to that one character to
the entire game
yeah and that's where the you know why
people call it god god realization it's
it's
yeah it's you wake up to the entire
field of experience the totality of
experience yeah no inside outside
no center no
there's not even a source of attention
right because
like every single particle
particle every single corner in this
yard you can probably
it's not like the the
character the vr
is actually looking at
other characters when you're interacting
with them you know it's just the whole
game let's just play and it's not the
interrupt
knowing itself
i love that um i'm gonna put that as the
quote in the thumbnail waking up from
identification with the one character
yeah
yeah yeah
i mean it's not that the character can
still be there
it's just like
now you can express it even more freely
yeah and then another video game analogy
is is kind of like in the game and then
you turn into it jump out of the screen
turn into it now you have all those
echoes now you can play with any other
now you're playing the
not definitely
yeah yeah and when
you you talked about this earlier i
think it's so beautiful um is that
the
sharpness of the intellect as it sort of
drops it relaxes itself and it's
attachment to all the icons and whatnot
and drops more into the heart and into
the gut and into emptiness and love
everything right everything nothing as
it does that the this
it's inexplicable it's like a new
dimension of sageness
opens up and like childlike innocence
has re uh emerged and um
so like when someone starts
um when they say something like do you
even know about this thing and then you
just look at them and you're like no i
don't know what is that i don't know
exactly and as soon as as soon as you
say that you learn that
you're
the power is actually there
that's where the power is
to say that
yeah yeah it's not to
fight back with a sword and
i know what it is i don't have i'm not
i'm good i know you know that's um
and um
something totally new as a as an
intelligence that's way more
way more intelligent thing yeah that's
why
i i always that kind of human into like
it's it's just a speck of dust within
this
infinite field
even a shape-shifter all right
right and yeah even just like
if i go like the
that thing changes forever right
yeah so and then
it's almost like it's hard to think that
if you if you're playing the batman game
you desire to think that
like this it doesn't it's the only the
batman game
and then when the batman moves the whole
war
render with him yeah
so that that's the experience right now
it's like the past and the
even distance space time all that stuff
was just constant
you know so like
maryland right doesn't exist even
even the
bathroom rent this is until i
render it right right so it's like this
moment one more render and that's not a
really good analogy for like any
permanence
yeah yeah it's just constantly
never stays
like nanosecond you know
but then you can't realize the
impermanence without dissolving center
because the senator is always going to
try to like
take snapshots at the wall like try to
solidify
recently you also
shared it like uh
as you just spoke about it as a
rendering it's that the whole universe
moves to the bathroom
the whole
yeah yeah as the universe moves like
that's what
it's
it's it's the actual fundamental energy
or vibration or the atomic units etc
that are doing
the moving itself to that location to
empty its bladder um yeah
yes
and that's also
different origination well it's like
when you walk
walking and this is even a webs of
conditionings and cause and effect it's
making every little thing
right right and then just yeah like just
going to the bathroom and pooping it's
just the universe pooping yeah
and then it's it's again it's really
hard to uh
to communicate
to
people because if you just tell this to
someone who
hasn't gone through this i think you're
talking about like
there's a really i feel more and more
openness
to this
as
um
the
way that it's expressed becomes more and
more clear so when we're sharing that
there's a going to the bathroom what's
being shared is that there's a
dependency on this wat planetary water
cycle and the consumption of fresh water
from the faucet systems of
taiwan or the united states and then
there's the
dependency of the bladder reaching a
point that then wants to
as it expanded now it wants to contract
and empty out the water into the
plumbing system that then goes right
back into the hydrological cycle after a
purification of sorts so meaning that
you're the whole web of dependencies
that you're that whole
endless
um infinite web
that
is that sensate experience so
and if the identity is sort of
decentralized to that web
um it can feel more free and more empty
and more loving and
in effortless and flow
um not a doer in the center and so i
feel like the analogies are becoming
more and more um available as though the
the bite of the apple and we've i feel
like we've also talked about this but
that comes from the whole dependent web
of the agricultural system itself and
the transit the supply chains the grocer
the monetary system the exchange of the
money for it or growing it on the apple
tree either scenario and then it goes
through the digestive process and it
empties itself so
and it goes right back into the cycle so
that
tuning into dependent origination and
these webs
that are endless in all directions that
make
the morphing of sense8 reality that
decentralizing your identity into that
is
its wholeness it's love um
so that i feel like it's becoming more
readily available um
recognizing these these dependent webs
and how everything shape-shifts like
that and sort of being the energy that's
doing that shape-shifting
yeah but
at the end even uh impermanence guys you
know as well
yeah because there's not even time
but
yeah that's been
like non-rising
like
i said not already
yeah but it's i think
everything that
everything on the conventional level
still stands it's not like we talk about
like all the
things whatever
you don't have
i mean
there's no space
time
i mean
optimal level that's true on the
conventional level
they still
play with them
yeah
right
yeah and
being
and not being at the same time
exactly absolute and relative at the
same time and
whatever that is
and isn't is
[Music]
you know it's that that you can't say it
and you can sort of feel and
you know be that
and not be it but it's
i've known i've noticed that actually
being more tuned into the absolute
reality
um
is sort of what the relative reality is
in a sense seeking
so
yeah
so don't don't get pulled out of
that
just because
there's
a ton of social conditioning that is
um
saying that oh
you can't not be your name you can't be
una local and non-local you can't do
that and then
getting sort of pulled out of of that to
play in some relative game when all it
sort of wants is to watch you just
spaciously love
their statements
um
and uh so and sort of let them gravitate
more and more towards a deeper
insight into
an absolute reality
so when you talk proliferation
that that i like to put it is just the
the white house and see if you stop
cleaning up these patients
at the microscopic level of system
um
there's no more
because all cleaning comes from
the stations trying to
tangle themselves
and take of themselves other situations
and try to take credit
that's the source about
i think that the thing that robert
the complete suspicion of any sensation
any cluster of station trying to conform
to another club
think of that question
and one of the last things like on tango
is that this direction of it
yeah
you know it's like
even after the sphere is dissolved there
it still can be a little like almost
like a ghost somewhere in there that
wants to feel like it's monkey things
yeah where sometimes things in here
might get solidified
when you're
certain things
especially things that
things are
conditioning because sort of senseless
literally like trying to like
pretend to look at that object
from the subject
so the arrow let's move the picture that
the guy right um the guy from which you
know that it's such a good one yeah put
that in right here one of the best ones
yeah what is it the first stage is like
conventional perception the second stage
um everything mine
where you see yourself and everything
your consciousness expands to be able to
mess the captain itself and then there's
the no-self
and then the last picture
is no self without a direction of it i
think that's a great
great
victoria
yeah it's just that um yeah the area of
attention even even just like sitting
down trying to meditate you see that
just directing your
attention to the object of meditation
it's also just happening by itself
the intention of doing some
where exactly is the point that you made
this decision versus that
[Music]
you can't find that point just like you
can't find a point
past
or between when this thing
yeah it's the same thing correct
goes along with the
thing too
i mean they did this
neuroscience
like experiment long time ago it was one
of the most famous experiments
like when i tell people about this
photoshop like my dad
was experimenting you know
scientists tell you to press the button
and then you press the button when you
like
before you consciously decided
you can actually see the
playoff room yeah and just try it before
you like pick up your phone you can see
the intention of that it's happening
before you move your hand on the phone
but where is that intention of the
intention of moving your hand to move
that phone
you can't trace it back to anything
again going back to the dependent
origination is dependent upon like
infinite webs of conditioning
now you can't chase back to the source
where it's like that's the source where
i decide to move my hand
ah
what a great way to deconstruct the
center and the arrow of attention yeah
the center of the dimensions is really
crucial i feel like oh
because with the center of attention to
construction you also dissolve the
background that's also one of the last
people of the background of experience
like
people who are like
i was like awareness or like
you know godhead actually they still
have a background as an option it's
still a foreground or a subject that's
trying to
really create itself
to that background
without the direction of attention
there's no one in the center and there's
no subject
objects
so the background the foreground becomes
one right yeah
so now every sensation is aware of
themselves without anything saying
trying to take credit
yes yeah
all commerce that comes down to that
really just sensation trying to untangle
other sensations
yeah yeah and then you see that there's
not even
you can't even watch thoughts anymore
yeah because once you dissolve the
observer or the direction of attention
you realize that thoughts
are embedded with sensation that simply
cognizes itself
so you have a thought
and then you think you have another you
think you're watching that thought by
doing mindfulness by applying the
direction of attention to that thought
but that thought is already gone by the
time you did that
so you have a thought and you have
another thought of you imagine yourself
watching that thought but those two
thoughts a
b are disconnected so it's not like dot
a and then oh there's thought a and i'm
witnessing watching thought hey now this
is awareness this is the true self i'm
disidentified from thoughts that's
another illusion because the source of
attention is another construct
because even that act is proliferation
it's like there's a new identity here
trying to like
untangle this some sort of a grasp
grasping yeah
exactly yeah yeah also also say she's
simply liberated themselves there's no
grasp anywhere
that goes back to what we're saying
earlier about the
center arising
to grasp on to a sensation and tell a
story about it and that is also the next
sensation the next whatever is around
yeah
yeah and not just story but physically
entangled
right yeah cellularly viscerally
entangled yeah yeah i think
this comes it's always the physical
means
that creates this that's why i keep back
to the notion of this whole process of
being a very powerful yes yes the
equanimity is cellular
it's cellular
yeah it's a
cellular like the only reason why you
don't feel like you're
buying a physical is another way to see
it because of the
solidity
that's why body is getting so powerful
for me
yeah that is the only thing i don't feel
like this guy no you're
it's all physical and all the traumas
it's more physical
exactly
that's why the chakras are like
such important thing it's not like shot
cars
shot across that just
body manifested in physical balls
at the store somewhere in your spine
a whole new level of
sky and lightness
yeah yeah
when those solidities and contractions
are
not
proliferating
just a
like a
yeah a pure and raw
sensate
reality and the universe [ __ ] wrong
condom
right in the
i think
that's my
love it
yeah
yeah there's so many things i used to do
that like
they just dropped away like things that
i
it's like the whole integration thing
going back to the beginning
like it just happens by itself and the
more it happens like a snowball effect
[Music]
and then after
it's more like wide
level it's just automatic it's like
probably just not going to
take you the place that isn't
going to allow us
itself
at the fullest and the deepest and the
most perfect
you know even though ultimate human
profession
you know what i'm saying
like i dropped something
i used to
trigger me then it's not like i'm even
trying to do that anymore it's like i'm
like making an effort to like
it's really weird man
that's sometimes
right
wow
yeah do nothing meditation is like the
best but it's in practice for
integration yeah
do you realize how much you want to
contract
just going along it's almost like you're
trying to fabricate a meditator or
well you can design just like this
so you go on this path you like the lip
really comes tracking suspicious okay so
you can dissolve it
right
right and the whole time there was no
center no one
yeah
like a big joke
just
that
non-centered
no oneness is
love
i don't even know what it yeah it's a
it's mystery
i mean
if it feels it feels like
it feels like equanimity equanimity kind
of yeah yeah i think
it's everywhere yeah love love has it's
yeah
it's um
right it's love too because you know
it's like it contains
all but it's a little different from the
kind of like
when i was going to the last stage of
the movie
that's why i don't use my work a lot
because it's cold love like if it's like
love is a it's a great word for it but
we say a lot of people are going to
associate with like
like the cunniling
explosion or
mr oh that's our well that's a part of
the process
i'm just saying it's
thinking the flavor they're
well distinct like you said it's a
little different
but but the only different again is just
the
level of
you know how much
you know
after a point where you feel like
everything's alive you can because
you're still like
usually the last thing on the chest it's
like when you're still waking up on the
chest
so that's the paradox about speciality
whatever whatever feeling that you're
experiencing it's actually the part that
you haven't talked right
like kundalini you still like
me right getting in the shock
experiencing all those communities
right
the
[Music]
yeah i like happiness
yeah whatever you're feeling as a ground
is the curricula for dissolution
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah exactly
that's really good
right right right your first
witness all you need
now micron is like you know
it's lovely energy you're dissolving it
but then the thing about this is like
after you dissolve everything
then when you put back those lengths of
perception their eye like we said like
the intellect that you let go they
become even more
yeah even more like you know
more pronounced
more
integrated
fuller
yeah
and the
equanimity is also sort of the
equalization
that
the
uncreated is the creator the unmanifest
is the manifest
that
the void is manifestation that exactly
um spaceship spaciousness is stories
of course all sensations
appearance
sources appear yes
yes that's great and it is what it is
yes yes yes
yes
nothing behind and i love that the
equalization is the equanimity
oh that's great
middle way again middle way again yes
yeah
again yeah yeah it's almost like when
you talk about like symmetry you know
how the psychedelic people they talk
about cemetery i think the same time i
wrote the article there
give an article
i have a real dean how like
he's like symmetrical right
like every point
not just point to every other point but
points to itself
so like at the end of suffering is to
realize symmetry like the mind is only
symmetrical
when there's no grasping of one
sensation to another sensation
right
and what we just said earlier it reminds
me of like just the perfect symmetry of
the
of awareness
nothing stands for anything else nothing
grasp anything else everything stands
alone by itself liberates itself it is
itself
in its own
space which is nowhere
that's nothing
it's the relief that we seek
and
did you ever feel like there was a part
of you that
still wants like it's like it's like
you had all this energy seeking and
sharing
like
realizing whatever and then
majority of that
do you ever did you feel like the
wrestling
conditioning wants to grasp
and it feels like you feel kind of like
like blue balls
right
yeah yeah well it feels like the surf it
feels like the surfacing
um
and the
and the dissolving and sometimes the
surfacing expresses itself
and that's usually done in a
in like a safe spacious
container
like a loving
uh blanket like a loving warm blanket um
so
it feels like this is the reason the
grass
the grass found on the secret condition
right right yeah right right it's just
it's just a
it's like a a constant
um
like
non-resistance
yeah
um a flow flowfulness like where you
know they're the
that proliferation of
of grasping
it's not yeah it's not
it it kind of blue bally um though
surfacing can feel you know blue bally
um
you where like yeah the sense of self
wants to like arise and cross it
reconstruct this now but you can't write
right right yeah yeah right yeah it
wants it and it wants to create some
sort of a new cycle
so
a new cyclone of of whatever um yeah
malevolences and and stuff
but
yeah and then again the only
way to uh write that voice is to
remember that there's no other way
right because you practice mindfulness
kind of direction
every time you try to direct your pitch
into something
start to the process
and it's like
it's it's kind of been this
kind of occupancy right
you can't really talk
it's really hard it's hard to talk to
this point it's
it's not like it's
hard to talk to like like
the spiritual people
[Music]
don't know what you did in a sense
into this genre
right
there's a new
silence that don't yeah yeah and then
yeah
you you
the spiritual people that you were
talking to just
look at you and they just see
godness
and yet presence
and then the regular people
look at you
and
you
just play with them in their regular
socially
conditioned thing because
he can't
um
not
uh when
it's
brought up like
just staring
as the abyss at
something solid that feels like it's
solid doesn't
it doesn't compute it like
i
as i as i've done that before that salt
that solidity wanted to punch
this in in its face
and so that's sort of the type of thing
that
um
that's this new
whatever however it begins expressing
itself it's some
way that like plays in all of these
capacities but
another fun way to play with it is sort
of like it's very iridescent um
so
it's
it's very it's very i guess it's also
very textural and like tasteful in a way
um yeah yeah
you know what you're saying yeah yeah
like you really tuned into the scent
you're really tuned into the sense the
sensation and it's very visceral
visceral right very physical that's why
i can't you know whatever physical
to describe not just the process
experience of it that's why they call it
my body
yeah
it just feels like it like
when you walk in the bathroom you just
walk on the street it feels like the
whole body it's a very visceral nice
very synthetic
and very light
it's not mental
right
it's very concrete
even though it's foam
but it's very
yeah it's meat
air embodied
yeah area
it's almost like air it's solidifying
back
but you know the form is hologram but
it's it's still a texture
yes
yes yeah it's not like when the chest is
like
right
yeah all the line
you're you're
like unbelievably tuned into the sense8
yeah right
i gotta recharge myself just give me one
second
the last thing we talked about
i like that
the physicality that's why they say chop
woody water
right
wait
it's just so grounded
you do
yeah
yeah we we've also been
playing with it as a
air element and an earth element
buddha had this inquiry it's like
dividing everything into like earth
element fire element and what's another
one earth air fire water yeah yeah yeah
yeah so in the beginning stages of your
inquiry kind of noting you just know
what everything is oh this is you're
walking on the earth and you're like oh
this is earth element oh it's impersonal
and if you're emotional oh this is just
a fire element
it's just the element of nature and then
you feel like
thoughts or whatever you're like oh
that's just the air element whatever in
the end the buddha unified everything
and said there's only the earth element
yeah oh right yeah i thought only yeah
what is yeah this physicality yeah so
even your thoughts your emotions or like
your highest states of consciousness
when you get stuck up in them when you
get contracted by them you just label
them as oh that's just earth element
my thoughts my feelings is not no
different from the trees the birds the
crowds yeah
right and the air is not different from
like the mud
yeah yes yes yes yes
hence the natural state
right
right
yeah it's like the air is
full with
endless
um symbols
that can then be used if you find the
needles in the haystack to
decondition the physicality
the earthlyness of it
um
and
i love that
it's just a new level of
absolute perfection when doing
nothing this is the freedom from the
need to measure
the need to measure yeah like the need
to make yeah
yeah yeah just going back to what was
saying before about the point in the
circumference right yeah the
relationship between the point of
circumference only exists because of the
ego trying to measure it but when the
proliferation of that center is gone
everything you know everything is based
on measurement like time space
the ego is based on measurement i'm
better than you i'm you know stronger
than you smarter you more spiritually
advanced than you
um depth this is closer to me than that
yeah so
that's good the cessation of measurement
also the whole notion i'm trying to
understand some questions
yeah
that's another that's a question it's an
answer oh that wouldn't exist without
measurements
right
that's right
that's a pretty direct pointing the
cessation of measurement
yeah the sensation of measurement yeah
even like that's why you know
in the middle of this talk you talk
about how even letting go of infinity
and eternity even like that's why that
still kind of presupposes a kind of
measurement
you know like
endless space or like some kind of like
time that's like you know that goes on
forever right it's timeless yeah
yeah
that's why it's really hard to put into
words because because words in
themselves are measured tools and
measurements
that's what made
nice that's a great i feel like that's a
great place to rap it's a great pointer
[Laughter]
i mean what more can we like the end of
measurements to say
yeah exactly
even be passionate i mean it's like all
kinds of quicker
i'm more concentrating this moment in
the next i'm more awake yesterday than
today
that's how measurements
oh by the way
my gosh still haven't seen it yet it's
on the list
i've heard it's amazing though it's
amazing yeah it's a really different
take on batman it's like a really good
mixture and in the middle way a really
good middle way of christopher nolan's
depiction of batman realism
and tim burton's depiction of batman in
like you know this fantastical like
gothic uh imaginary environment because
the criticism people had of like one was
like it was too realistic oh the batman
looks so [ __ ] weird it's how i felt
like that too i felt like batman is too
out of place in this perfect ordered
world
because crystal milo is very like you
know logical very like everything
straight line every card is like
it's just totally like a left brain kind
of
filmmaker
and then it works i mean batman
definitely works from his batman
definitely works but it's a it's a it's
a sort of like a response it's an
antithesis to tim burton's batman tim
burton is like super poetic in a sense
like very theoretical and super right
brain
and the new one is that the mattress one
is like a mixture of both
yeah that's the progression of any path
too you know like you know hey girls say
you have like a thesis
and the antithesis then you have
synthesis
so every system of learning or
progression comes from that you know at
first the dualities you know first you
have this inner dialogue and that end
about in the fusion of the two that
transcends
both sides of duality and i think the
new batman movie did though but then the
new batman movie is going to become the
new faces
and then in the future there's going to
be an antithesis in response to that
forming a new thesis
that's the evolution the progression of
everything from the microscopic level to
the macroscopic level to the cosmic
level
that's another way to perceive like
contraction and experience
[Music]
and then like the mask of the batman is
like almost looks like henry
like the before it was like you can
actually see his expressions really well
like before you can never really see
what batman is thinking when he's like
in the suit but then for some reason the
new version you can actually it's very
mental it's like the most mental batman
it's just like thoughts it's there's a
lot of like thoughts you know what does
it really feel like psychologically to
like be batman right
and i feel like nolan's version was like
very grand just like oh here's a sky
view of gotham city and it's like
you never see any close-up of like
batman like dude like picking his
fingernails and [ __ ]
but then like in mary's version you can
see like this just like little details
of like that these little textures of
sensations that like actually points to
how batman is feeling like at the
microscopic level it's really
interesting yeah you should check it out
that's all right
check it out
nice
and it's hot movie is about like trauma
release too
it's just about it's about the the
traumatized the traumatic
it's about how batman dissolves his
conditioning
i don't think they got into too much of
that in the early
it's like batman doing shadow work and
it's very universal too
i'm still only like 24
on my rcm 9 game
the game is [ __ ] hard man
it feels good
feeling it like a
magnetism and a
morphing of that magnetism
i'm excited to
i think this talk is very different from
the other ones we had
right i mean we get into some of the
stuff but um
from a different like
it's almost like coming in from the
outside more now yeah
but also within as well as both you know
but also within as well exactly both of
those yeah yeah both of those yeah yeah
yeah
going back to like the thing with the
riley yeah yeah
right
from the boundless
from that outermost in and also from the
inner yes expansion and contraction
exactly
i think at the end your realization kind
of just goes back into you it's like
there's nothing outside i said
ocean ocean absorbed back into this yeah
yeah for the
people that didn't know this analogy at
first you're a droplet like the ego is
the droplet and then as you go on the
spiritual path the droplet goes into the
ocean and then starts to dissolve into
the ocean that's the process of
dissolution
and they become the infinite ocean
that's where the awareness consciousness
god consciousness face
you feel like you're everything but then
but then the whole ocean is absorbed
back into the drop and then by that
point both finished
yeah
there's nothing outside of it that also
goes with the vr uh knowledge that also
goes with vr
but it's not solipism though
it's not materialism either nor ideally
right
i've been looking forward to how
this would morph and
it seems very fruitful and
i'm
i'm really excited about
this continuing to blossom and us
playing together in person and creating
more and just seeing what arises it's
just
it's very it tastes really good it feels
really good
it tastes like it tastes like you
it tastes like home it just tastes like
what you always are before the
conditioning piled up
right so it's not like you're
transcending to some other world wrong i
mean there is that but at the end you
just like
that's what you have always been it's
just you you know just
self and no self this is what you are
yeah
any final words yeah that's let's do
this little final bit yeah sure
so
this is i think our fifth conversation
in our series yes and
it's a it's a special series it's a
it's probably my favorite one on the
channel
thanks man i mean i have the most like
expressive talks with you
like i have the most talks with you
i don't think i've ever done any
podcasts more than once
all right that's so beautiful man it's
so cool
and i i feel um
there's been a lot of good like feedback
um
so
we would love to hear from you guys um
you guys want to drop a comment and let
us know your take on this uh fifth
episode
we would love to hear from you
um
uh also um yeah let us know how you feel
about the evolution of these
conversations uh because it's been a
while since the last one we would love
to hear from you about that
and um
i don't know any ideas on collaborations
that you guys want to see how you'd like
to see this continuing to blossom and
play
um
and
um
also uh if you felt like this episode
was insightful for you
like the video
also subscribe if you haven't yet
share the video that's another really
great way to
continue
generating the catalyst
and
also frank's
social channels are all linked below
also so go and
uh
definitely check out some of his most
recent content on youtube his most
recent video distillations have been
fantastic so go and check those out if
you haven't yet
subscribe over there
and also go and check out his instagram
his website
um go and check him out follow there
also frank's still doing
coaching yes
yep
so
send a
dm over
for i think email email is better for
that i don't check my themes that much
anymore right right do you have my
website
yeah i have a coaching thing on my
website you can just thanks
yeah yeah
yeah that's probably the best way i mean
um reaching out yeah i think email and
via email yeah
you can find my email and website email
and website exactly
um
and
yeah i'm just really grateful for us and
this vibe
it's so good
and hopefully uh that was a great time
man
yeah
it's coming soon it's coming
um
nice yeah that uh that feels really
complete
yeah you can find our links also in the
bible below check those out
and
just really feel the perfection when
doing nothing
stop measuring yeah
good stuff
all right
bye guys infinite love bye